proposed in view of some items on the
agenda item five is taken now and that
item 10 is would withdrawn from the
agenda they both relate to four
counselors who are no no with us
do I have your agreement with the
agreement of Council I propose that we
defer until the December meeting the
invitation to counselors to address the
passing of counselors pain and former
councillor Stewart bees their deaths are
very recent and if their families were
to wish to join us it would give them
the opportunity to join us and hear any
I'm sure hear the adulation and support
that we would like to give them I now
invite therefore the consciousness any
counselors to address the meeting if
they so wish and remember it's the
formal counselors honeychurch and Lloyd
can I just remind those of you to be to
speak directly into the microphone to
ensure your words are picked up on the
recording Thank You chairman chairman
can I suggest that we take the tributes
to Trevor first and then move on
afterwards rather than combining the two
Thank You Trevor Honeychurch chairman
those of us who remember Trevor will
recall a highly energetic enthusiastic
counselor full of ideas some of which I
even agree with know like a number of
local councillors in Stratford
Trevor worked for the nfu but after his
retirement he was still full of energy
which he used to contribute to the local
community extremely hard-working Trevor
could deliver leaflets as fast as any
video I know Jaron an inveterate dog
lover I remember one of the leaflets he
put out featured Trevor the large
picture of his dog named paws
and he had a large rosette attached to
the dog assuring voters that pause was
supporting Trevor which he probably was
Trevor was a great support to his
daughters one of whom ran a local pub
and restaurant but after leaving the
council he eventually moved to be near
other family in Wales he immediately got
involved in the community in particular
supporting the local life folks I must
say charity claim is great shock to that
of his death at a relatively early age
but I'm sure we will all retain very
fond memories of Trevor and his work
thank you
I cut some more kind of Pemberton Thank
You chairman in a political sense I
would I would echo those words from from
from Peter there I also knew Trevor
because I also worked for the nfu group
and I found that his energy and zest
found its way into his business and
career life as well and I really would
also just like to record that in a
professional sense at that time I think
this was before either of us were
anywhere near this place he was always a
supportive and informative and very very
grounded person who was able to assist a
sort of a young whippersnapper like
myself and did it with really good grace
because I really didn't know what I was
doing at the time but he he let me off
the hook very very gracefully and I just
wanted to echo that in every aspect of
his life he was energetic he was
knowledgeable and he was supportive
indeed his his daughter actually is now
my next-door neighbor so I did see him
relatively recently and certainly he
certainly hadn't lost any of that zest
which was a good thing as he appeared to
be embarking on redecorating his
daughter's entire house single-handedly
so all round a really good guy and I was
I was pleased to to
him and I know that his daughter
although she cannot be here
it's grateful to know that he's been
remembered here
by his political colleagues counselor
frankly Thank You Jay
Travel was a neighbor of ours he lived
just just down the road from us and my
husband worked for the NF u so we've
known Trevor his wife and family for
many many years and I came to know him
latterly as a very very enthusiastic
fellow supporter of of my particular
party and very much a radical thinker I
just like to add to it he was passionate
about the I have to say and I should
have written it down it's awful the it's
completely gone I will stand up in a
moment and say national national trust
and news Hospital Association sorry I
just got to the both national trust in
News Hospital Association which he often
combined and he often took over hostels
at the weekend to make sure that young
people could actually pursue those
interests
sorry about my senior moment everybody
else would share memories in which case
I'd like to move that the council notes
with regret the death of former
councillor Trevor hunt Church counseled
with the Stratford Avenue a new war
Newtown ward from 2008 to 2012 and
extends its sympathy to his family and
friends in their loss
and therefore like to move on to
councillor Keith Lloyd off you go
chairman M the Lloyds of long beam
contributors to the public life of
Stratford his father Ted Lloyd was in
fact thorough secretary to the
forerunner of this council and played a
large part in the setting up and
transition to Stratford district council
he was also an elected councillor
O'Meara Stratford as well so Keith
followed in the family footsteps at
various times the district councillor
the county councillor town councillor a
mirror Stratford an astonishing record
Jim um I know from conversations of
residents in the town how how highly
regarded Keith was this was borne out by
the huge turnout at his funeral so he
was well regarded within the town Jim
and I'm sure that you were aware that
the past mayors of Stratford are
recorded on panels in the Town Hall and
going back many hundreds of years and
it's always inspiring to stand in front
of the panels and the boards and look at
the hundreds of people who have served
this town over the centuries
I imagine Keith would have looked at
this and seen the names of both him and
his father with immense pride and I
think the family can share in that pride
Jim for the devotion of dedication of
the lloyd family to this town thank you
Celso forchick just sort of person
although when I got elected in 2015
keith was in fact he was he was the
first councilor to actually go in
touching congratulate me soon after that
many dealings with him as a county
councillor obviously his case work would
have dovetailed with some of my casework
as a district councillor told me some
great things on interaction with the pub
we have great charm and great sense of
humor as well
and sort of it kind of helped me how how
he could sort of deal with the casework
on a very personal note and I learned a
lot from that I found him to be a great
listener and took on board other
people's views this in turn shape those
decisions he made as a counselor and I
take great pride to have known him and
had many political debates with him most
of which did occur in a pub and it's
very evident his love for his wife and
children and you know obviously when I
met him and that's my continued
condolences onto them and somebody said
to me that that Keith was a real
character and he really was and sadly
Stratford has lost one of its biggest
characters thank you Thank You counsel
counsel sent chairman next week we will
pass a milestone you might not want to
worry about that but I'll tell you what
it is the milestone is it was 20 years
since I was first elected to this
council and when I came that year
the autumn October council meeting was
just after the by-election so I was
thrust into the council chamber within a
few days of being elected and there sat
on the other side of the room was Ted
Lloyd who is the effect Keith's father
and indeed a member of this council and
indeed so I'm fully aware of the length
of service the Lloyd family have given I
know nothing about his past life setting
up this council but I could imagine but
he would have his finger in the pie
therefore Keith did follow being a good
I knew him but as a member of this
council and also in my life as a county
councillor when keith was also elected
and effectively one thing I remember
about Keith was he used to show me
personally unnecessary deference in my
view I'm not used to it I'm used to a
kick up the ass another pat on the back
so consequently it's it was unusual but
he'd always greet me well and I feel and
many other members of this council have
lost a friend with Keith's passing and
effectively the world is a sad place
without him thank you no suit comes
legatus I can't add a great deal more to
that sir mr. chairman but he was a
friend of Ulster he recognized Ulster as
one of the principal market towns so
within the district area and he would
always present that all our civic events
when I when I look back now at the mayor
the mayor's events the district council
when Eric stood I had the pleasure of
being the chairman Keith attended all
the events and he'll be greatly missed
in the community of Ulster Thank you
Thank You counselors for those eloquent
words I'm sure they will be appreciated
by Keith's family it was a very good
turnout for his funeral and it was clear
that he was somebody who Shawn in many
many different circuit circles and the
very brief time I met him which for
about a year there was always a little
candle in the corner which was Keith's
turning up there gentlemen are there
four move nobody else has any words they
wish to make the council night notes
with regret the death of former
councillor Keith Floyd counselor for the
stratford avenue in newtown ward from
2003 2007 and 2011 to 2015 and
Stan's sympathy to his family and
friends in their loss as I've already
mentioned we will I'll invite eulogies
from and comments from fellow counselors
and our next meeting for Eric and Stuart
I would just like to announce that
Eric's funeral will be on the 26th of
October at 12 o'clock in I assume it's
in Ulster we haven't got details of
Stuart's in which case yes thank you
chairman if I may I'm just looking miter
Stewart's funeral is on Monday the 22nd
of October at two o'clock at Oakley
would thank you very much all right
after that sad starts there's
proceedings we will now move to the
formal agenda and I'll call upon the
executive director to report the
apologies Thank You chairman in mr.
Webb's absence and what would have been
his banal from a meeting it will be you
will obviously be attending the December
meeting but I can give apologies for
councillor Atkinson Barnes gommage
Coghill house Lawton richy's and
Williams
thank you if we move on then to the
second item which is discloses of
interest do any councillors have any
just interests they wished Asterius no
in which case we'll move on to item
three you've all had a copy of the
minutes I know a secret proposed or a
seconder for the minutes of the meeting
held on 16th of July 2018 Thank You
councillor Barker are you proposing them
Thank You councillor fielding thank you
all those in favor of accepting the
minutes as they stand thank you
any against any of stepsons I think you
which case read we now then move on to
the minutes out sorry the announcements
firstly I'd like I'd like to give the
vice chairman invited to receive her bag
of badge of office and what should
unable to attend a previous meeting so
okay today
I just like to take this opportunity to
thank you mr. chair for having the
vision to appoint a woman as vice chair
and it's very important centenary for
girls I put a very political mum and so
she encouraged me to stand but I've did
that with the support of certainly
called women to win and hashtag asked
her to stand and 5050 Parliament just
giving a shout out if you know any women
that you think should get involved in
local politics please encourage them
with 20% of the intake we need more
girlf to stand
I'll give this my best shot thank you
right moving on to my announcements it's
been quite a busy period firstly I would
like to sort your neutral one but the
leader cuts our Jefferson council st.
and I were invited to attend the annual
school speech day that cares see for
myself and I'm sure my two colleagues
will agree I was bowled over by the
school's extraordinary performance the
Upper Sixth had a record-breaking year
with 86 percent of a level papers graded
a star to be making cares the night and
9th highest ranking co-educational state
sixth form in the country 52 students
obtain 3a grades or better including 17
who obtained the grades required for
their place of dr. pitch colleges at
GCSE three-quarters of papers received
the new seven to nine grades which once
again placed cares in the top 10 of boys
grammar schools nationally their
performance in the world of drama music
sports whether on the field or on the
river or fencing art and culture was
recognised both locally regionally and
internally in what respect of one
athlete Commonwealth European
and World Stages on top of the
remarkable experiments the upper six
total over 6,000 hours of volunteering
engaged in activities from sports coach
into conservation within with a diverse
range of organizations I invited the
headmaster to come here today because I
felt this council should recognize
success when we see it sadly he's not
was there I was unable to come but he
proposed to other people to come who are
probably far better qualified because
they are representing the students
themselves ladies and gentlemen I'd like
to introduce the head girl
Tan's hazm in shape and the deputy head
boy Joe Barrett who was sitting behind
us we'd like to stand up who have come
here on behalf of the headmaster and I'm
sure we'd all like to applaud their
success ladies and gentlemen to ket's
[Applause]
thank you very much November the 11th
marks the hundredth anniversary of the
end of World War one Toni perks
Craig Bourne and Wendy Buckley of
Bishops it chetan have worked tirelessly
to produce a roll of Honor of all those
who lived in this district and went to
war but did not come home as many of you
will be aware we will be publishing a
roll of Honor with the names of all
those who died from this district on
Thursday the 8th of November with a
service of dedication again supported by
pupils from qez but also of the school
from my own ward there of course many
many schools exemplary schools across
this district so I chose one for my own
ward because I thought I should but I
hope every effort will be made by
members to attend this important
commemoration of our history and our
sitting citizens who gave their life for
our freedom the service will be focused
around two minutes silence of the level
of clock with the last post and revoir
they played by a bugler from cares so I
very much welcome as many of you to
attend as possible it has been a very
busy twelve four months since we last
met one of the events I went to was to
celebrate two businesses in this
district receiving a Queen's Award for
enterprise and I know our vice chair
last week attended a further queen's
awards ceremony on my behalf Thank You
penny for that I also attended that the
National Youth markets award here in
Stratford it occurred to me that we do
not do enough to celebrate the success
of our own homegrown businesses
and therefore announcing this year there
will be a Chairman's Award for business
which will be awarded the last council
meeting of my tenure so the most
successful small business in the
district to be judged by a panel of
councillors and outside experts still to
be appointed now here's the catch
I would like members to nominate a
maximum of three businesses in your ward
and a minimum of one who you think
should receive the Chairman's Award for
business we will be publishing there are
criteria for what businesses are
eligible and that will be circulated to
all members but we have six months and
the reason I want members to be involved
is I want it to be a district-wide
competition we're based in Stratford and
many many many businesses are based here
but we represent the whole district
which is why I want every ward member to
produce at least one business from their
patch which they consider deserves to
win the Chairman's Award for business
right moving on as I said it's been a
busy four months with 28 and 28
engagements across the district in fact
across the county and I'll run through
my program very briefly including a
summary of the trip to Fuji which as you
know I came back from the beginning of
this month so on the right in front of
you that's the that's the list of where
I've been if anybody wants go to details
I can send you a copy of it I know it's
quite small councillor Barker I
apologize it's been a busy few months
now which one work
David it ain't where we're at we're off
we start off with your work University
that the degree ceremony this actually
led to a useful introduction whereby the
leader and I subsequently met the Vice
Chancellor with a view to business
opportunities that the university is
looking for we'll get this one going in
a minute David you'll to move it on one
Thank You teri that we then attended BT
of just BT of the treat at DM Kyneton
which was as you can see a lovely
evening movie on David rag Lee Hall the
national game fair attended there with
along with the mayor of Stratford this
was a commemoration signed up with
delegates from Qatar about a a Joint
Working Party put together moving on we
welcomed our colleagues from Peru early
in August they came to see the site as
you know they've given us a peony
pavilion which is going to be Richard
somewhere in Stratford and they came
here to review that site
we then had the two Queen's Award for
enterprise awards to the green sheep
company and George frag dolls on an
evening with the omni-benevolent found
up in Nuneaton
I mentioned earlier on the National
Youth markets Awards this have been
moved down from Manchester to be in a
more central place Stratford was picked
by the National Youth national markets
groups and this was a competition for
the most successful young market trader
and again the mayor and I
based on the Friday to welcome the
distracted on the Saturday for the
award-giving I would like to receive
copy the Gideon Bible and then about
three weeks ago Princess Anne came here
to open the new council hospital which
was good news she was also wouldn't
warranted that one instead of myself
come David we then went through we met
here the general secretary of the party
in future and this was all part of the
process leading up to the signing of the
Accord the shakespeare birthday plus
david and that is the signing ceremony
with the different people relating to
the development of the new city of or
the new town of san wing and that is the
outside it actually reads the three
draft dramatist park two members of the
Shakespeare Birthplace trust and two
members of this council myself thank you
David that is the picture they're
holding is an after suppression of what
the park will look like now for those of
you remember my pictures from last year
it was a plowed field a very very large
cloud filled with some holds innocent
drainage if we then move on to the next
picture that is twelve months later that
lake did not exist last year in fact the
depression didn't exist they have made
it because they're going to build a new
theatre on the banks of that lake to
represent our own Royal Shakespeare
Theatre more like the Swan than the
current a big theater they've even got a
copy of Clopton bridge going across
towards the theater and then David those
of the three poets who are being
celebrated tank tchangzu Shakespeare and
Cervantes
and once again food who doesn't focus
entirely on its artistic history it is a
very modern city it is growing as a
grown considerably from last year thanks
David after that I went back to the bear
pit theater who put on a production
theater for those of you note as you
don't know you should see it
what is encouraging is when we went last
year to food we were given a
demonstration of an excel Twelfth Night
by a school on a school theater the bear
pit theatres are looking at the
possibility when the Chinese come over
here succeed the installation of their
pinnacle video as to whether we can
actually put on a performance a part of
their own poetics tantrums whose play
within the pavilions been given bit
challenging because they haven't got any
people experienced in Chinese Theatre
which is very different but it is
something that might happen we're trying
to work on it
thank you David we then had the high
sheriff's opening of the legal year in
samaris Warwick and David the opening of
the mob three days ago which has to be
in about the Wester stay in the last six
months and regrettably the open of the
mob did me
right let's try again oh it seemed to
come back to life get right so as I said
very busy very busy period and if
anybody got the questions please
if not we'll move swiftly on to the rest
of the agenda and I would now like to
invite the leader of the council Thank
You Jay
I'll be fairly succinct as with the
chair and I attended the cares speech
day and I have to say I would echo
exactly what the chair said it was
unbelievably impressive it really was
all the things that have been done over
the last few weeks council house and I
visited Presley cycles which was very
interesting I've also had about ten
meetings separately with local
businesses and organizations the key one
perhaps was with the Vice Chancellor of
Warwick because as the chair said there
well was born campus is a hundred and
ninety-one hectares I meet he's going to
play I think 20 critical role in the
medium to long term future of the
district as people know there is being
issues with the alliance between
Warwickshire Police and West Mercia and
there will be a special meeting of the
police and crime commission held on a
day to be arranged in the near future at
the Coventry and Warwickshire let
meeting today it is very obvious that we
are the only district that he's working
on an economic and industrial strategy
and it is worth commenting that when we
had a stakeholder event 20 people turned
up and this will really help inform the
strategy and actually making rigorous
and well grounded just to pick up again
and what the chairman said about the
links with China
what I also raised at the
this morning was about the links we have
with China and how has a much wider area
we can actually exploit those links to
the full both for the benefit of
stratford-upon-avon the district but
also the wider area that seemed to be
well received and there will be a paper
going to the next left board that's all
chair Thank You leader I might just add
for members think I hope this counts on
the leader in the chair that have been
invited to go back to China in November
trust even award and this is to the
council itself and has nothing to do
with any other party as the leader is
questions please feel free
after the meeting or now comes moss game
and I merely wondered since I understand
the 15 the pitch we discussed at the let
board meeting this morning I cannot say
anything until the news is released
right dávid nagy chairman chairman I've
been asked to make an announcement in
relation to an ambiguity within the the
Constitution as members will recall at
the meeting the council in February the
following was included within the
committee procedure rules and it goes as
part of his/her inherent jurisdiction
the chairman has authority to invite an
individual to speak again as part of the
discussion and debate on what they have
heard to check facts issues or issues
more broadly in doing so the Chairman
will observe principles of natural
justice taking advice as necessary now
this additional wording has been
included in the Constitution under the
section participation of other
individuals groups or bodies and has led
to some confusion as to whether that
relates to councilors attending
witties or not to remove that ambiguity
it absolutely does relate to councillors
we do feel that the word in this land
ambiguous and we will be seeking a
further revision to make them more clear
with a future meeting the council
thank you
we now move on to a topic we've been
trying to get on the agenda for previous
two meetings which is to record the vote
of thanks for our previously it account
sacrosanct i'm delighted to say that he
is with us today having been conflicted
and soundly absent from previous
meetings and therefore i would like to
open for anybody wishes to make any
comments all about council sent council
moss Thank You Jay
just like to say Chris was leader for
seven years there's a new counselor I
must admit I was rather surprised by the
number of Hoops that had to be gone
through to get this call strategy
adopted and I have to say a crystal weed
through I'm also very fortunate that are
being left robust finances and a very
good officer team it makes my life a lot
easier so thank you for that Chris Thank
You chairman chairman I first met thanks
of a st. Nick Reddington by-election in
1998 to which he referred earlier and I
did my very best to forestall his
political career but failed overland
year since then I've seen his strengths
and his weaknesses and know that you see
mine but today let's concentrate on
these strengths no matter how much I
complained about them at the time
German firstly
I like his sheer capacity for hard work
I rarely came into the council without
seeing his car in the car park and I
know that besides his council duties he
took part in many national and regional
local government events nor was this at
the expense of his ward chairman I never
received any complaints from residents
that they were feeling neglected
chairman I'd mentioned secondly his
depth of knowledge of council workings
his attention and grasp of detail you
could talk to him about anything in the
council and he would know what was
happening and perhaps arising from those
two could I comment also and reflect
your two points about his major
achievements firstly the core strategy
seeing through a huge piece of work with
many competing interests and secondly
the challenge of austerity with a
reduction in financial support first
council from the government that
resulted from that he sought through a
major reorganisation reorganization of
the council and because this action was
taken early the council was left in a
better financial position than many
other councils chairman oh I'm sure we
all recognize his contributions this
council and wishing well for future
Thank You chairman council organ Thank
You chairman Chris he has worked
tirelessly for Stratford district and
his council he has made a huge
difference and that is what counts his
legacy will live on with us as work
continues to achieve the right outcomes
for our residents
I thank Chris for his hard work and his
determination
during his time as leader of this
council and I am very pleased to see him
back in home council watery
I just want to add my um my comments
there saya I was a newbie winner when I
arrived here and Chris was leader and
like you know very public some of us are
ups and downs I've had where I've been
on the council and I would always say as
leader Chris was fair he was consistent
and he was exceptionally loyal and there
were times when I think you know Chris
and I over policy we've had our
differences and always like was he'd
give you an airing you could go and bang
on his door and go in there and have
that chat and he certainly earned my
respect and my loyalty and you know for
that reason it was you know I think I
think the way things happened was
disappointing for us all about Switch
all reflect on loyalty sometimes and how
important in politics
loyalty is and how we should perhaps
treat those who have earned their
loyalty well Chris thank you for your
time as my leading counselor goodness
well I wasn't quite a newbie when when
Chris became leader I'll actually served
a year and it became apparent to myself
and I guess to the other members of this
authority that the time at that time
required a strength and an enthusiasm
from a new leader and we at Ulster who
had the pleasure of supporting a
councillor Saint to become leader of
this Authority we realized that this
authority was in a different era within
a difficult time and required strength
commitment and understanding for it to
move forwards and I can remember now
saying to Chris sue Adams roolewd me how
do you fancy being leader Chris this
council needs a bit of additional
support in this very difficult period of
time it was in the in the members room
any hon Bernard about it and a few weeks
later he he confined to the city was
going to run through all I can say is is
that
did a wonderful job a wonderful role the
we only have to look at how the
community has responded to the position
that he's now in now and the community
also identified and recognized the
wonderful work and the fantastic
financial position that he's this
leftist authority for the new leader to
take on his role Thank You councillor
courage thank you yep I suppose it's
more personal
really so from me as a just as a
councillor but also I think for the
villages of steadily and Mapple were
greens specifically Chris has been a
very good friend to those villages he's
he's represented at the Alex hospital
he's helped with reducing the impact of
development from redditch on that Wilber
green he's helped with the co-op and
persuading them to to move forward on
the whole of the center of our village
and many other projects which is still
ongoing and struggling so really on
behalf of those residents specifically
thank you very much councillor Richards
take your chair and Chris I think it's
fair to say your list of achievements
both as an elected member of this
council but also as leader is quite
phenomenal not least of which I'll call
strategy what which was a very difficult
thing to get through you've led us
through some quite tough and taxing and
challenging times your knowledge of both
current policies but also the history of
this council is unparalleled you are a
wealth of knowledge for us and I'm
looking forward to working with you
again or further in the future as we all
debate later on you have left this
council in a very very good position of
strength and so thank you for that on a
personal basis I think it's quite
incredible that you've been a member of
this council for 20 years when you're
first appointed I wasn't even old enough
to vote
so when I was elected as a fresh-faced
29 year old with ambitions you've helped
me greatly in the time that I've been
here from the very first day I walked
into this office all the way up to you
showing your support for me by
appointing me to your cabinet last year
from a personal perspective thank you it
has been valuable and I look forward to
two more times together in the future
thanks counselor at all Chris as a new
cancer last year
you have been incredibly kind and
patient with me as I tried to learn the
ropes your breadth of knowledge is
inspired and also your determination to
get back to work after a period of
illness is admirable and I just thank
you for your kindness and your
consistent understanding as I try to
understand the role of being a counselor
thank you
well Chris I don't think that many
adjectives that I could add the words
that we've heard today hard work kind
supportive a deliverer and somebody
whose breadth of knowledge was
encyclopedia I think I don't think use
that word so at least I can add
something so I'm sure we all recognize
your huge contribution would you like to
make any comment
well can I think colleagues for their
praise as I said earlier I'm usually the
one that gets to kick up the ass rather
than the pat on the back so I'm in a
slightly difficult situation here but
I've always attempted to take on a role
and take that role seriously please
don't be uncharitable this take until
now to do this because in April
had to for council meetings which I had
to miss because I was confined to
hospital and the next one in July I had
actually been discharged but I was still
undergoing a number of procedures as an
outpatient and I was banned from driving
at the time so that precluded me from
attending the the July meeting there's
been quite a huge gap between then and
now for me to appear so can I thank
colleagues for their kind words
well perhaps examine the downside of it
and on another occasion but in reality I
think I appreciate your gesture and I
appreciate the fact that
[Applause]
but therefore like a moon of a form or
those of thanks to our former leader
counsel Chris Saint can I have a
proposal the council organ and the
second councilor Richards all those in
favor thank you I'm pretty sure that's
unanimous thank you Chris we therefore
move on to point seven which is public
participation there has been one
question raised by a member of the
public copy the questions together where
the answers have been circulated to all
persons in attendance mr. Courtney I
hear you've received a response to the
questions would you like to come
you really you received response to a
question already to Gateway steering
group do have a supplementary question
mr. Cokely could you press the
microphone button
thank you online court where I represent
winner H green residents Association we
knew each degree is a fairly large
housing area and it is adjacent to what
is known as the red each Gateway project
and quite a large development I've read
the reply to the initial question and I
and members of the Association are
dissatisfied with that reply my question
is I'm sure that your counsel supports
the principle of the local government
democracy and that only should justice
be done but also seen to be done given
therefore the perceived bias of the
current chairman of the Gateway steering
group through his close connection with
the developers this is undermining the
credibility of the steering group which
was established will you now appoint a
neutral chairman for the future group
meetings please and if not why not
Thank You councillor Pemberton would you
like to respond thank you for your
question thank you Thank You chair thank
you very much mr. mr. courtly I take on
board what you say the steering group
was set up through the auspices of the
Planning Committee I do not have any
direct authority to change or alter the
composition of the steering group itself
as a portfolio holder and what I will
commit to do however listening to the
dissatisfaction that you
the residence group have would be -
perhaps to arrange a discussion with you
at a later date understand that in more
detail and perhaps to discuss with
planning west chair whether it would be
appropriate to reconsider the
composition of the group I can't I
cannot give you any commitment of any
change I'm not in a position to make
that change happen but I'm quite happy
to arrange to sit down with you and I
would invite the chair along as well at
a convenient time and place in the near
future
I'm not certain twenty-third so that's
next week okay okay perhaps if I'm sure
we must have your details I'm sure
through Carolina's office a week we can
set something up probably probably the
best book and give you at the moment
thank you mister cordially we then move
on to a massive determination by the
council and we go on to the state of
district report and I call upon the
leader of the council to consider the
report Thank You chair produced by Simon
Poole field
overall I think the district is in
excellent shape our most metrics we run
ahead of either national or Warwickshire
numbers we're going to work very hard to
keep it that way
because it's important one thing I want
to make clear on a personal note I think
economic performance is extremely
important because it enables everything
else I think we've got to be very
mindful over the fact that at the moment
it may well appear that the future might
not be as rosy as we might anticipated
nevertheless we start from a very strong
base
but however they're looking through the
current state of the district there is
some particular points that I want to
pick up if one looks at page 18 a
quarter of the district is aged 65 are
over
that is one of our main issues in terms
of dealing with the merging population
and they are the fastest-growing sector
of the population we've also got the
issue on page 19 of we've got the
highest median house prices in the West
Midlands that's the same for the lower
quartile district ratio of leading house
price to incomes nine point four in 20
September 2017 there is no doubt about
it that the high price of houses is a
major issue for the district and the
ratio of house prices to earnings is a
particular source of stress
it has to be said that there is a
limited amount the district can actually
do to impact that it's one of the
downsides actually of extremely low
interest rates over a long period if we
then look at page 20 very interesting
comment that around one in ten people in
there working either full or part-time
beyond their pensionable age in the UK I
think that is set to continue we are
also as a district and that importer of
workers which has some significant
implications for connectivity and
congestion if we look at qualifications
again on page twenty one forty seven
point nine percent of residents have an
NVQ for qualification of high or higher
a rise of ten points on five years ago
which i think is a very very substantial
change the other thing and it's one of
these foundations on our economic
performance there are a hundred and
fifteen businesses per thousand working
age population fifty percent greater
than Warwickshire
surprisingly the largest occupational
sector is manufacturing with 12,000
employees even more important because
although as a famous economist once said
productivity isn't everything but even
long run it's almost anything gross
value added per head the proxy for
economic well-being was thirty two
thousand five hundred seventy eight
pounds in December 2017 what it shows is
twenty seven thousand two hundred and
ninety one a significant bow performance
England is twenty six thousand one
hundred fifty nine so we've Stratford on
the urban district gross value added
figure is in the top ten percent of all
local authorities of the UK forcing a
relatively good standard of living we
must not forget that because that really
does the pain so moving on if I look
back page 25 and achievements and clear
events point four point one it should be
noted the budget for 2018 is likely to
be last where the clamps will reach they
use revenue support run from central
government grant is reduced from three
point nine million in 1314 or 111,000
2018-19
I think it's clear that one actually has
to accept that the financial pressures
going forward I'm not likely to abate
are not likely to grow our budget has
been supported but through the impact of
increased housing and prosperity new
homes bonus payments have been confirmed
to be 3.8 million
2018-19 there is a real risk than before
new homes bonus gets tackled it really
will put pressure on our district in
April 2018 we approved expenditure of
2.5 4 million and the spending
priorities are actually listed there in
looking at our corporate strategy when
we looked at it we thought we would roll
over the current strategy for year into
2019 because then the new council could
actually properly consider a four year
strategy just in terms of some of the
achievements interesting enough an awful
lot of it around ledger centers
Stratford leisure center mere measure
center of the Year in the flame Awards
2017 major contractor everyone active
name facility operator of the year i'm
stratford leisure center awarded
excellent bike quest I recognize has
been the third highest performing
facility managed center out of more than
400 across the country we've secured
funding to improve birmingham road and
it's SDC the town council an MSD
promotions organised stratford-on-avon
his first three day victorian christmas
market which went down exceedingly well
and not only benefited the market
operator but also benefited local
businesses so that's if you look at
objective 1 on page 24 of issues of time
that's a flourishing local economy that
is absolutely critical and that is what
i am devoting a lot of my time to thirty
one couple of very key points to pick up
377 new affordable homes enabled in the
district
so televised household recycling rates
in England
moving on to 3333 where the
non-constituent member of the West
Midlands combined Authority and the
mayor Andy Street will be visiting him
on the 31st of October to gain the full
understanding if he asks from our
district commend this report to Council
I think it demonstrates how excellent
the performance of the district is and
explain a very firm foundation for the
future and now we have to maintain that
thank you leader does anybody have any
questions comes to moss I'll be very
brief chairman because I'm well aware
that this meeting is looking like taking
longer than we anticipated
so just one question chairman page 23 of
canceled Jefferson's statement and I'll
read it out for members who have nearly
one quarter of businesses stated road
traffic congestion was the major problem
and that was nearly double the
percentage recorded in 2013 in other
words chairman the position is getting
much worse and I think we would all
accept that now chairman if we look at
the recently issued the place for
business at the heart of England copy
the a3 400 Birmingham Road in Stratford
suffers from congestion Warwickshire
County Council with support from the
District Council has already secured
funding for highway improvements which
they are actively pursuing for
implementation in the next
years chairman does he not think that
businesses and residents will be
dismayed in a loan that this council is
not pushing for action until 2 or 3
years time Thank You councillor Morse it
has to be said that in the stakeholder
meeting we had through the key issues
actually raised one was around
congestion one was about connectivity
and the other one was about public
transport I would actually agree that
two to three years for Birmingham Road
is a very long time we will be pushing
the county cals lot very hard to make
sure it is done as quickly as possible
and I think one does need to remember
that at the end of the day highways is a
county council issue or not a district
council issue I would also say that I
raised the issues of connectivity and
congestion at the left today and I
certainly intend raising it with um
discreet when he comes to visit us on
these issues
[Music]
I am on the ground safety partnership
and I would like these figures checked
because from my point of view antisocial
behavior seems to have increased tenfold
certainly tenfold in my ward and I just
wonder if other counselors are having a
similar problem thank you Thank You
Chancellor just a point these figures
will refer to 1718 I would actually say
that I am picking up exactly the same
message as you and certainly it has been
raised at the police and crime panel and
it will be raised again because I think
there has been a changing trend I have
access to the south in terms of thank
you chair on this when I went through
this and just a general comment on its
format is every year it's exactly the
same if I might say just a small point a
refresh of the way we address these
questions we really helpful because just
the format's a bit dull one but I've
wrote down four things what specifically
are we doing about the over increasing
you know elderly population is district
so specifically what are we doing and
you referred to it leader but you know
but that's not a new problem if I may
say so what are we doing about it and I
would like to avoid the discussion that
oh what's the county matter what's a
district if we can't operate as a
district and do something then we should
have a separate debate about unitary
authority but that's not on the card
as as district what are we doing
secondly I had the affordable housing
issue you mentioned yourself 377 houses
fine but we know it's not enough we know
it's not addressing the problem so what
are we doing to get more than that 377
thirdly I've got the issue here about
pay imbalance of no one's mentioned yet
but if there are businesses in this
district that are not paying women as
much as men might presume that's the
bias of the imbalance what are we doing
about it it's all white having a
conversation but why don't we insist
that there has to be something published
to make that happen
and last but not least it's a point that
a councillor Morse made and it comes up
in a question later on but the traffic
survey the traffic strategy for this
council and the County Council has
broken one the two things under our
previous leaders tenure that I think
we're material things we've done over
the last four years
what again specifically are we doing to
address all those traffic issues the
businesses and our residents who are
addressing it just seems with a lot of
talk there's a lot of excuses it's not a
district issue it's a County issue or
police issue but if we're getting paid
what are we doing about those four
things thank you I think that will pick
up one major point and that is that some
things are our direct responsibility and
other things aren't that's the way the
world works in particular in terms of
policing the police have particular
powers we do not have and that in
reality if one wants things done the
first port of call to find out where the
evidences is the police it's not the
District Council I think if we look at
the elderly population there is work
going on at the moment in terms of the
joint needs analysis in various areas of
the district that needs to be pushed
through and I actually agree with you
that as the results come out we
to be seen to be doing tangible things
at the moment we need the evidence to
decide what to do in terms of affordable
housing we need far more affordable
houses as you say we are pushing
developers to build as many affordable
houses as they can the local housing
killed me a paper of which will be
produced in the very near future may
well help address that but if one thinks
that they're going to be hundreds of
extra affordable houses frankly no there
aren't there might be many tens or even
100 but it is not going to be a
fundamental step change if we look at
the pay imbalance I don't know what we
can do but I'll find out and if we can
do anything I'll do it the traffic
issues at the moment an awful lot of our
time and effort is focused on bringing
the southwest relief rule to fruition
that as the County Council's old figures
say will be a relief road for structor
domain so that should help but there are
much broader issues in terms of
congestion and connectivity and we will
not be able to address them on our own
and a lot of this will be down to
influencing either the left or the West
Midlands combined authority to actually
help us this is actually where being a
member of some of these organizations
really starts to deliver we simply could
not gain the funding to do this on our
own
councillor Harris
I'm concerned as to the issue disorder
it's different facets of the STP to get
certain key people in for us to us
forensic questions and then when we get
those answers
councillor forchick I guess sort of
three things that sort of highlight it
to me
the population getting older is quite
clearly going to create and in social
care housing as well this effect is is
gonna have long-term pressures on this
council as well as the County Council so
we do need to take action on those
things also I noticed that house price
is obviously very very high I was
highlighted by councillor Jefferson but
combined with young people actually
living in this district is it's creating
a crisis where we're hollowing out this
district of young people and having a
district with older people in it that
made care this is going to lead to an
even greater crisis than we already have
particularly with falling government
spending central government spending
into local councils so this report
highlights very very blatantly and
starkly the challenges that are going to
be presented to not just this council
but councils across the country and
action does need to be taken and we can
do things within this district we have a
housing company ready to set up we don't
need to build tens of houses leader we
can build hundreds of houses
to account for that thank you thank you
thank you council Authority I think it
is very interesting because I just like
to link this with a point that you made
about the format I think when we do this
again not only will we change the format
but actually we will drive it through to
what actions we can actually take to
tackle some of the issues and I think it
is a very fair point though we have to
be much better at identifying the
actions we can take and certainly on the
economic and industrial strategy we are
driving that through to what we can
actually do I think when councilor
phytate mentioned about the number of
houses the local housing company can
actually build there is a financing
constraint around it which is something
that so I would not expect it to be
building hundreds
any more questions or points on the
state of the district report okay
in which case we need to move to the
recommendation and that is to stage
recommendation state of the satphone 11
district is noted and the issues raised
and considered as part of the budget
making process for 2019 2020 the second
stage that the approach the developers
the corporate strategy 2019 2023 as
identified apparent 94.9 is noted is
everybody happy to take these two
recommendations together so I couldn't
can I have a poser for the two
recommendations come to the mills
seconded counts the gray all those in
favor all those against any abstentions
thank you ladies and gentlemen we then
move on to point nine planning committee
meetings I've outcomes with Emerson as
planning and building services portfolio
holder to introduce this item thank you
Jim
thank you Oh Thank You chairman members
this this item is before you really
because of some issues that have arisen
over the last six months or so in terms
of our ability to support the work of
our two planning committees members will
be aware that each planning committee
consists of eight members with a quorum
of five we are 36 in total and as you
will also know how to take a lesson from
Casa legatus
we're 36 in number and historically we
have not called upon members of the
cabinet to serve in committee and in
essence there are there are two members
of cabinet who do serve on committee but
six of us do not and in addition back in
2015 we we did resolve to reserve to in
essence reduce the pool of members who
could sit on on committees that along
with of recent times where a number of
members have suffered ill health I'm
glad to see that a number of our back
hale and hearty but of course we we we
talked about the sad passing of
counselor pain earlier today has put
some strain on our operations and we've
got very close to a position on more
than one occasion where we have not
looked as though we're going to be
caught up for particular planning
committees that has implications in
terms of not only the workload for for
officers or committees but also for for
our residents those who bring planning
applications to us and there are
potential consequences if we're unable
to determine an application within the
required time scales
where
may actually take us out of the loop by
applying for non determination to date
we have been able to avoid that
happening but we are running quite close
to the margins and so in conjunction
with with with officers we've been
looking at how we might in the short
zone try to resolve that and what is
recommended here is that as a first step
that pool of counsel is eligible to act
as a substitute be increased to
encompass all members of the authority
say for the leader and the holder of the
planning and policy portfolio both of
those posts clearly creates potential or
at least a perceived potential for
conflict and it would not be good
practice for either of those post
holders to sit and determine planning
applications running alongside that is a
requirement that for training we're one
of a few number of authorities who
insist on training but I think that it
may well be something that we have to
come back to and that leads to the third
recommendation that officers go away and
you will see within the report a number
of medium-term options be considered in
terms of future number of planning
committees structure of planning
committees delegations and potentially
even looking at the whole structure of
planning committees because we aren't
going to become any more than 36 members
anytime soon
and so this problem is not going to go
away so so so members of this council I
bring forward a recommendation under
number one that we extend the pool
number two that the training
requirements apply to all counselors so
in essence all counselors start to bring
up their training hours and that's under
number three officers be tasked with a
medium-term piece of work with the view
that we bring forward for in advance of
the new municipal year a set of
arrangements that can enable
and committees to work properly and to
work efficiently in future holder I'll
now sit and take any questions thank you
there is a an overriding an overriding
requirement for members to maintain a
certain level of hours and failure to do
so does have a financial penalty for
members in that they can lose one
month's allowances so there is a penalty
I recognized that trading is over us but
we didn't come into this and expect an
entirely easy ride we are expected to
make decisions
we're expected to make good and grounded
decisions and it comes as comes with the
territory that we have to do some
training to to do that and I don't shy
away from that and it can be as
difficult for me as other members to
find time and sometimes the enthusiasm
for various training training sessions
but it is a must and certainly we do
have to and I know the members working
group is very keen on this need to have
a sort of reinvigoration of the value of
training and certainly if we got to a
position where it became mandatory that
certain types of training are done I
think that would have that effect but
that it's not decision for me that's a
decision for this
it's my obviously any change to training
our requirements will go through the
member development working group and
certainly officers will feed into into
that but does that give you what you
need Perry
Thank You chair it's just a point on
training if I'm a counselor pemberton if
it could be any training be extended
beyond specifically Thursdays at five
o'clock because every single training
for the last twelve months
tends to have been on a Thursday at five
o'clock we are trying to encourage other
members to counsel who happen to work if
you work on a Thursday and that is the
only time you can attend a training
session it does make it a little bit
difficult if it's not more flexible
Thank You chair I would I share some of
the difficulty being a member who has a
real life outside outside of this
building as well in fairness to officers
the move towards standardizing the time
and day of the week of training actually
took took from sanding from other
members but I think that we all need to
try and understand how we can be
flexible how we can be more innovative
about how training is delivered and I'm
sure that David will take on David Orban
will take on board your comments because
we do need to give every member the
opportunity to attend training whether
that be planning related or for any
other issue
I think counselor Perry's point is well
made and I think we will take it on
board and see what we can do
thank you therapy has to be further
points that we should raise thank you
kinda pension for a comprehensive
commentary we've got three
recommendations again four members are
happy we could take these on block to
make kind of a proposer and a seconder
recommendations one two and three I
think because the brain is proposing and
I think Thank You councillor courage
second idiot right all those in favor
anyone not in favor any abstentions
right carried unanimously
one abstention thank you the mister gave
we now move on by prior agreement I some
terminus being withdrawn we therefore
move on to item 11 and that council st.
as chairman of the audit and sentence
committee to introduce this item Thank
You chairman there's been some debate
for a while about the governments of the
parish there has been a joint parish
council between the two neighboring
parishes of Henley it's not unique
and effectively it's a very practical
way of running things forward but if
there are parish council they can't be
regarded as a town and Henley in Arden
is often recognized as a town within our
district and therefore new arrangements
are sought they did go down this Avenue
a couple of years ago but discovered
that there was a financial penalty for
the timing in that there would have to
be fresh elections conducted on the 2nd
of May 2019 which is the day the rest of
us will run for reelection then of
course that would be a practical way
forward now bringing the matter forward
at the moment time scale is tight we do
meet if we're going to proceed with this
governance arrangement we do need to
follow the recommendations before us
today they would then have to be at our
December meeting confirmation of the
process after a period of consultation
and then at our February meeting finally
adopted of the new arrangements to make
a Town Council of two wards with a
specific number of councillors elected
for each of those two words I've spoken
to
and I think I'm promoting this after all
Thank You chairman it's really just to
concur with what counsel stated actually
said it will be good for the future of
ending our methods can be finally
resolved and thereby supporting exactly
what been said by character phone
well members page 48 we have
recommendation to Council from the audit
and standards committee that the
community governments review for bow
desert and Henley and Arden commences in
accordance with the terms of reference
as appended to the Jen report and with a
view to reporting back to Council on 17
December 2018
I'll we agreed to go forward with that
recommendation
thank you we move on to item 12 ships on
soil neighborhood developed plan and
that council Pemberton was planning and
building services portfolio holders from
chooses item thank thank you Jeff I
should be brief with this item the ships
and understand neighborhood development
plan has come back before cabinets
following on from the referendum held on
the 6th of September where there was an
eighty-seven point three three percent
yes votes the cabinet then has resolved
to bring the referendum version of the
Neighborhood Development Plan for ships
and understand to this council with a
recommendation that the plan be made and
adopted with immediate effect so that it
becomes part of the development plan
process for the districts and at the
same time that this council places on
record its congratulations to the ship's
Ananse town neighborhood development
plan team for all of their hard work in
bringing the report and indeed the plan
itself to fruition really just seeking
confirmation of castles acceptance of
the recommendation but happy to take any
squeaky questions if needed I cut some
more to cosmos
are you satisfied
just a quick cancel Pendleton could you
somehow move left or right something
wrong with you all not you but your
microphone whilst you're sorting that
out I don't even need recommendations
outcomes parameters clearly you had a
comment comment yes of course indeed say
that I was pleased with the outcome of
the result except a hundred and thirty
three people decided to go along to the
poll and boat against however that was a
complete minority but effectively
probably demonstrates the fact there
were a few difficulties along the way I
was
Brenden version has been widely accepted
because there's a challenging place
batting for them without the town
council being there however be that as
it may the situation is strengthened the
issue of there are some contentious
there are some contentious proposals
lurking around in the background has
taken is fair share of the housing
growth for the district
the proposal to Council
Thank You counselor Saint cuz the
Barkers that also award known for ships
and uShip I don't think I need to add
anything Thank You mr. chairman Thank
You councillor Barker other than the one
comment I would make comes the st. I
think every resident of every settlement
in this village believes they're taking
the brunt of the development strain in
this district but I'm sure you recognize
that when you are owned you are in
resistance for the very first of
themselves we have the recommendation
are not repeated councillor pendant
really doubt very eloquently we have
recommendation one and two again I see
no point is splitting them if
everybody's agreed I'd like to take this
as one item you happy with that
therefore the recommendations as read
out or are we happy Casablanca
I propose it proposed both do we have a
seconder comes to st. when you reckon
the second seconded by Councillor st.
I'll we agreed let's go ahead thank you
right we then move item 13 committee
reports for information only council st.
orders and service committee yes
chairman the minutes have been published
for the two meetings I wasn't sharing on
the 26th of July but was on the 24th of
September but I'm sure the meeting
everybody have any questions for Council
st. case we'll move on thank you this
committee accounts with Jefferson I've
asked counsel to receive the minutes of
employment and appointments committee
held on 10th of July any questions
because Jefferson move on overview
descriptive committee Barker to note
maybe than you do last council tonight's
the minutes of the 27th to the 25th of
July on the 5th of the questions for
council bulk up
cabinet comes to Jefferson okay sorry
calipari regulatory committee Thank You
mr. chairman I have pleasure in asking
council to look at the minutes for the
regulatory committee that was held on
the 6th of July very happy to ask for
any questions thank you we'll move on to
item 14 questions we have received
number of questions
14 have been received they've been
circulated to all on a separate sheet is
anybody well starting off the number one
book I'd like to ask everybody has a
supplementary questions councillor
Barnes is absent with received apologies
so I'm assuming the work the second
question from him move on a question to
cancel fortune just on the last part
where it says the potential for local
housing companies next year to be
considered by the cabinet
Thank You counselor for a check I'm
confident it will be considered open
dead pretty soon
of my cabinet colleagues however they
will actually come to a this is this is
the direction of travel as an authority
but clearly I can't I can't prove the
debates but I think my own thoughts
looking for us to have the best possible
solution for us to to have the maximum
number of Thank You councillor rights do
you have supplemental question counsel
for a jury first question you have a
question yes thank you very much in my
ward who are elderly and have
considerable concerns about this I'm
pleased to say that people who come
collect bags but some of these to
collect the other issue I just wanted to
raise was that residents do have food
caddies and some have the black boxes
and I wonder if any advice could go out
about using those to help augment
getting waste out of homes
the only issue there that I would say is
with waste bins we need to be considered
I think you can see frigidly your second
question you had a little bit
disappointed when I look on page 25 at
the corporates of priorities because in
2080 19 there is a chunk of money there
but when we look at next year there's a
nice big fat naught so it does concern
you this answer is that it seems to be
moving considerable way into the future
to even consider a CCTV camera which has
actually been probably is there any
money knocking about that could actually
afford a camera in this place over the
next
[Music]
highways issue
Thank You Ralph
do you have supplement question
tell Justin I can check on that in
detail and get back she counts along
cancer most to have some question there
is no reason why the rest of the
information section one
thank you it's the moss we move on to
cancer Rolf you have a supplementary
question
chairman I'm not sure right
Kosar ravi responds if there is one
it'll do
you'll hear from cobol council morse
question this is a question about
housing supply figures it seems to
extend ever further into the future
before we actually build any houses and
I note in the reply I'm being told that
we are now removing sites from five year
supply those without full commission
we're significant progress is not yet be
made and that suggests to me chairman
there are GLH significant progress has
not yet been made and my question was
why could I be told why progress is not
being made so pemberton to that Thank
You chairman and that's a different one
and I've still got the same buzzing I
just must be made
to be canceled mores to be fair actually
it's a sort of miss reading of the
situation all that we've done is to take
a cautious approach to the calculation
of the five-year housing land supply in
terms of the new NPP F that came out
earlier in the summer and we've been
correcting because there is there's
nothing to report in terms of any
slippage and just to give members
officers all of the major sites across
the district to ensure that track and if
blockers do come up that they're
identified and the appropriate resources
are brought to bear nothing fundamental
has changed about and it's merely a fact
of us
Thank You Joseph Overton council Barca
might I just help with the definition of
echo or eco energy company obligation
Thank You Council Barca
we've therefore move on from question
comes from Audrey you've had a response
cause of Audrey I have a supplementary
chair so just to put members to the
background here about 18 months ago with
Stratford park-and-ride there was an
incident where 100-plus sort of canting
we've been afraid employee races a very
sexist of you same boy races but guys
and girls hood cars all souped up zoom
around the park hood right there make
noise they lower firecrackers they drink
all that kind of stuff I got so many
calls that night it's not even in my
patch and I got so many calls that life
residence I went down there at 18 months
ago and kind of sorted my own eyes one
policeman in a car sort of turns out to
be fair the guy looked terrified
kind of went off nothing got done but
afterwards we put in track to your point
leader you know this council I think led
discussions with the police the county
all sorts of organizations to put in
track a policy to try and stop it
happening again what actually happened
was the next time an event was happened
and just just to add to the fast the one
of the reasons the police claim they
couldn't be there in numbers is because
they just changed the organization that
monitors websites all models actually
advertises these things because the
police to change organizations they
weren't tracking all mods so bit of a
farce
anyway they put in place or maybe to put
to put guards on duty on the Sunday
night
Morris house and I turned out and the
guard said there's no toilet available
I'm going home I walked off so we
thought that's great so Morris and I
were there were the bouncers for the
evening
just cuz this question is a bit woefully
and doesn't really all the answer
doesn't really address anything from
well my point is in that given that is
all started off again on Sunday I went
back and be fair there were two security
guards there this Sunday having
requested it but I've had I've had
correspondence that says that money will
run out in the next couple of months so
in the spirit of the fact we're working
so wonderfully with all these other
organizations can we please do our bit
to contribute to the cost of having
regular security guards on a Sunday
evening at Stratford Park a ride when
these events have been advertised the
next advertised one is next Sunday Lee
though but can you work with all these
other organizations so we can defend our
residents from the behavior increase
definitely happening in my ward I'm
astonished at the complacency of this
answer I think it's really appalling
frankly from councilor cargo I do think
it's a shame he's not here
so hopefully you will answer my
supplement but in the core strategy when
the transport strategy there are whole
range of objectives that are set out
from reducing car dependent C to
negative impact of air pollution provide
increased resilience transport network
Road Safety promote social inclusion
none of which were addressed in this
answer so who my um my question on this
one given given where we are is what you
know nothing's going to magically happen
until we actually get on and execute
something
there are loads and loads and loads of
things in this transport strategy which
we've all talked about in the past
they've got more responses bla bla bla
and anything else why aren't we doing
anything today to actually move this
forward
it ain't gonna magically happen we can
all sit here till next May this is one
of the MPS key drivers and it looks like
we're doing absolutely nothing I think
that is shocking and I would ask you
leader to kind of put in front of us
sooner rather than later some actual
actions of what we're doing to execute
this strategy Thank You councillor for
Audrey I will make sure there is a much
full of response to this question for
next time
I'm moving on point 15 questions to
leader unknown about questions to lead
up to questions maximum per member with
a three minute time limit and total flow
counselor I was unfortunate but I'm told
you first on the buzzer both questions
does lead to think that the multi-story
car park on Main Street industry has
been declining for many years and with
still no action taken to regenerate the
carpark and the surrounding area and
second question the Birmingham rarities
in my ward and we heard earlier from the
Council of Audrey that wants to see
action here in Stratford to get this
work started early rather than later
once the leader has been to the county
to get some feedback I'm just if he
could get back to get back to
Thank You Windsor Street car park yes it
is on the agenda because we are very
aware work needs to be no need for it
needs replacing the time scales are
probably in the order two to three years
on the second will on on firming the
road yes because I also live close to
Birmingham Road so I've got a very
vested interest in this so I will chair
some exactly what is happening and get
back to you counselor right mic up two
questions the first one concerns
training I went to a training session
I was in the head straight that this
space is provided possibly my we have to
refer anyway so please please because I
want to become a mentor to the staff
because they deserve it but they do need
those moments when they need to reflect
on what's going on because I do believe
and they're doing their best we should
be helping them to do their best as well
so that was my first question my second
question is about the ready Eastern
Gateway one of the things that I would
really like clarified about that
particular group and I've been on their
offices we've got residents we've got
cancers we've got all sorts but was not
what was not clear was when if we take a
vote on something who's going to vote
closing title to the vote so those are
my two questions thank you thank you
Council right council Jefferson the
answer to the first question is simple
yes and I believe work he's really not
on where that could actually be now the
answer to the second question is I
honestly don't know because we need the
terms of reference but we will look at
the terms of reference and get back to
you on that
Thank You councillor Saint Chairman I
wonder if it could be acknowledged
though Warwickshire County Council has
recently revised its local transport map
the first edition was produced about ten
years ago I know as County Council and
they've just done a revision this is for
preferred lorry routes throughout this
district and beyond but obviously is
this
it would appear that virtually all the
major routes and roads in
stratford-upon-avon town are marked as
read routes which are primary movement
routes for heavy transport and heavy
transport if you take the advantage in
training to live he's getting larger so
my question is in revising the local
transport man what did the County
Council do to consult with this council
as part of the local councils Charter
which I believe exists to make certain
that we are consulted on issues that
affect our patch Thank You councillor
st. I'm sure it's master concerns all
councillors thank you for that council
aside I'm not aware that we were
consulted certainly I've seen nothing
come across my desk that indicates any
attempted consultation so I will take
that up somewhat strongly any other
questions
sorry council of ordinary two questions
chair first is on the canal quarter this
time last year I recall there was a
cabinet meeting which an open session
discussed the arrangement potential in
the canal quarter with Barclay homes spy
told me leader you wrote a very nice
dinner they organized earlier this week
or last week what has happened since
that cabinet meeting a year ago have we
made any progress in those discussions
with Barclay homes are we making any
progress in building those 600 homes in
the canal
kino mothers so it is moving forward but
as you will appreciate it is a rather
complex project and also we the council
own some land there so it's a case of
bringing a lot of moving parts together
to get the right result
your second question counselor Vaudrey
so just a follow up of our one ready
Gibbon um give us what the changes in
the EMP PPF about its impact if we if we
don't hit certain housing targets of
what that means for our local plan I'm I
can get nervous given where we are with
canal quarter Bishop turn shot Airy long
milestone gay delight horn all of which
seem to be slipping and I accept them
all complex but they're all slipping at
what point does our five-year housing
supply become at risk so what I would
ask if I supposed to do because you may
not over the top you go ahead leave
there but could a letter be circulated
to all members that if in the next week
or so I suppose that if all of those go
nowhere budding it's the end of next
March from we do our next numbers if all
of them have got nowhere we still have a
housing supply
[Music]
Thank You counselor Morse this obviously
is a normal part of the process where we
have to identify Reserve sites work is
ongoing on any further questions for the
leader nope in which case we'll move on
to know some motion
[Music]
Thank You councillor Morse councillor I
think your counts of forgery Thank You
chair I wanted to speak in favor of this
motion I may be minority on the
conservative side for doing so but um I
happen to think I strongly believe we
have got to this divisive point as
councilor more said where society is so
split there can only be one solution and
I've come to where we are in a minute
31 solution which is to have a second
referendum because without this my side
is never gonna believe in the diversity
of where we are will think we're always
mislead at the start and but if there is
a second referendum and we lose well you
know we've haven't really got a channel
to go down one of the reasons I support
a second referendum is I think we'll win
the debate and actually I hope we never
have we never leave the EU I still you
know a small percentage of me holds out
that we may overturn this ludicrous
decision in my view so I want it pretty
self-interest reasons that I think
enough people have gone from being
threats it ears to being remainders that
we might actually see a difference it
will still that you look at Donald Trump
in the u.s. it still amazes me how many
people are hardcore supporters of him
they will still be 45% plus in the new
world looking at looking at brexit I
don't understand why but that's their
choice but at the margin that small
majority I think will be in favor of
remaining than not all those bricks it
is
strikes me they break down into three
groups there's those that are in the
Jacob Riis small camp which are you know
whatever the courts little England
that's absolutely fine now he assured me
the other day that you know Dover will
be absolutely fine I think he's gonna
have his nanny there directing the
lorries and that's fine that's that's a
world he lives in it's not my world you
know I've given given credibility his
his Nana used to go in canvas for him in
Glasgow when he was a looking for sea
but there we go the second group is
actually where my sister falls into it's
those who are concerned about
immigration and I have to say I
absolutely respect that view that
certain people in certain parts of this
country I WIMP acted heavily by
immigration and just fill enough is
enough and at least temporarily want to
pause the border
I do accept that group the third group
are this mystery to me who somehow think
this is good for us economically but
they think this is going to be great
that we're gonna be in the camp of
working with Donald Trump
but he's going to do us a great deal and
we're gonna save the world and have this
new world order that we're gonna be
there shoulder-to-shoulder with Donald
and make a difference they are smoking
something I mean this week goes legal
and they've been spent too much time in
Canada I mean cancer House loves Canada
maybe he's been there bit too often
recently but that what really concerns
me this this group about you know almost
I don't understand why they don't join
brexit and for those Tories who you know
are getting upset whatever it's fine but
that group that group in our party is
about to potentially risk the Union and
it's a serious risk they're potentially
gonna risk a Labour government it's a
serious risk this week we could have the
Tory party collapse we have a leadership
challenge we could go to it all for what
economists for brexit they come out have
this big press conference the first
speaker says oh just let you know I'm
not an economist he was old when he was
advising Margaret Thatcher he's beyond
herself I date now that was it one
economist did we think so he lied a bit
like two old forests with history 150
musing heat million he lied because it
was economists a breadstick there was
only one economist in the money it's a
fast where these guys are and where has
it got us
it's got it to this point where none of
us know what's going to happen the next
few weeks or months it's gonna tear this
country apart whatever your position you
come from you know it's gonna be an ugly
ugly ugly solution whether I mean I'm in
the camp of yeah we probably will leave
a very be know the brexit in name only
solution where actually some labor
people could probably vote for a
checkers pass rather than the Canada bus
solution and you get some sort of
solution that may go through but I think
there's a chance it won't go through if
it doesn't go through you then trigger
the vote of confidence you know even if
she survives of total competence and I
would say unlike some members some of
whom are here today I don't call for
tweezers are made to be kicked out of
the party like some people in this room
might be I actually think she's done a
fantastic job under the most abusive
circumstances if she was a man she
wouldn't take half the flat she's taking
Tories are treating our leader right now
and I think you know good for her
hopefully she can get some bill done but
is absolutely shocking we've got to on
that point I will stop and say please
please because we've been told to vote
against this motion so much for the will
of the people
please thank you
Richard Thank You chairman
no surprises here that as they leave
voter I am in full agreement with
counselor Barker and we regardless of
which side of the bracelet the main
debates you sit on and this this issue
has been without doubt the most divisive
issue this country has faced in living
memory we live in a democracy and on
June in June 2016 this country voted by
majority to leave the European Union the
residents of this country therefore gave
our government our elected members of
parliament the authority to negotiate
and agree our exit from the EU block by
passing this motion today quite simply
we'd be ignoring the will of the people
this is a national issue and it should
remain councillor Vaudrey earlier talked
about loyalty and politics politics this
opportunities showed loyalty to the
residents and people who live in this
country who voted by majority to leave
the European Union we should be showing
our solidarity and support for our
negotiators and to give an up whole the
democracy of this country I wasn't going
to make this point but I will Castleford
Regan talks about the economy and the
likelihood
there clearly showed British goods
exported to the EU in the year 2000
in which wealth who are there by choice
yes
I fully support a democratic system or
undermine it tell me what would happen
if a people spoke different it's
ridiculous no that's not what a
referendum is about it's a powerful tool
and it is used sparingly it is the voice
of the people and it has spoken whether
or not everyone agrees with it
it is democracy in action and it is he
did and of course everyone has a right
to protest and to shape opinion but
equally a comment on the proposed motion
by Council Barca we have a proposal we
have a seconder from Council Richards
so individual trying to people are going
to be disappointed
democracy in the country is beginning
democracy is not a snapshot decision for
all time but a response to changing
situations if the views of people are
not tested before this momentous
breaking of ties built up over decades I
fear there will be a dreadful backlash
this motion Council for chick Elsa mills
sorry thanks mr. chairman thank you
I actually got the call from Peter
Moores would I support a motion I was
actually in Versailles at the time but
was chairman in college so many of you
know I'm a remainer or someone would say
Ramona
firstly I'll Prime Minister tweeted me
voted to remain and I must say that
she's been given the poisoned chalice I
don't envy her her task anyway and
despite what people say I cannot think
the better person to leave the country
at the present time my main fear is that
is that what is going to happen to the
UK when we as we know it once we leave
the EU and just a reflect on my time in
campaigning I campaigned on the streets
of Ulster worry and lemmings and spa now
the majority of the comments not all to
me well a little racist as an example I
spoke with one resident of Lebanon and
asked him to support the remain campaign
and his words were not likely there are
too many fraud language around here and
there all along benefits I thought he
was strange if we do leave the you I
just hope that it does not give people
like him license to be abusive to anyone
who appears not to be British we want
our country back was another thing or we
don't like the EU laws when asked which
laws one one which laws one particular
person told me that she thought it was
the France by the EU to say that we must
have straight cucumbers
as she preferred curly ones when I
pointed out that reason for straight
cucumbers is these are packing and what
other laws didn't she like and we should
like to see no smoking ban in pubs
kicked out if this was an EU directive
the answer came back for their forum so
as far as I can see it's too jolly good
reasons to leave the EU
I'm also fearful on where our economy
will be once we leave the you I've
spoken with a number of MPs and asked
them will we be better off financially
and more powerful once we leave the UU
the outside got back each time we've
seen three the prettiest motto there
will be opportunities not one MP was
able to say whether we be better off and
more powerful
in my opinion if it's such a good idea
that we leave you why leave the EU why
is sterling in such a bad way against
the US dollar and the Euro Isis it was
not a case before the referendum indeed
on the night of the referendum we saw
the pound plummet against the dollar
which is not the cap on sins it's all
very well for it to steer to say it is
the will of the people but I'm pretty
sure they did not vote become poor even
in Sunderland where they voted to leave
the EU Nissen is saying that men with
qualifications are most at risk of
losing their jobs if trade barriers go
up after brexit so once again we have
the ordinary workers who lose in
contrast and according to a survey by
the UBS that Union Bank of Switzerland
you didn't know most millionaires
believe bricks it will make them even
richer it is quite simple for me at the
times of Redman campaign if the Prime
Minister David Cameron thought his quest
to stay in the EU the chance of
extraction Exchequer George Osborne
thought it best to stay in the
the governor the Bank of England my
carny food better saving you and even
the leader can we talk about how this
affects this can we please drop your
clothes unless you tell me how this can
affect this council itself well I
so yes I would decide whether they still
will we won't get an extra three hundred
and fifty million quid
kicking out foreigners isn't we already
suffering meanwhile fewer patients
grexit ears also promised that we would
stride the world while latter-day Walter
alleys opened the foreign markets to our
trade it's complete nonsense
we're scrambling to copy deals that he
already has with over 60 countries not
only how we go to lose access to the EU
market which accounts for half our trade
when the US and China see our
desperation Williams they'll force us to
open our markets chlorine wash chicken
leave campaign slogan was take back
control Theresa May makes one client
after another
exactly what Johnson gave two years ago
we're currently one of yours big powers
making the rules but because the Prime
Minister was desperate not to lose all
the EU advantages will end up as a rule
taken this tail between our legs brexit
less clout in the global stage at the
time russia's flex it could even imperil
the peace process in Northern Ireland
eased communal tensions between
Protestants and Catholics unless we can
stop border controls which the tears
will no doubt seek to trash your idea of
a people's vote by calling it the second
referendum it's not in 2016 voters have
a choice between the reality of staying
in the EU and the fantasy campaign once
we know what the deal is we'll be able
to compare the two realities it's not
been democratic it's common sense
grexit ears will no doubt say we're bad
losers and such but in a free society
everybody has the right to speak their
minds it's undemocratic to try and
silence us others may say the people are
so sick and tired of whole business they
don't in another vote many people do
want to get it over and done with our
task is to persuade them if this is such
a big deal they do need to focus on it
one more time the good news is that many
voters realize the importance at the
moment they're suspicious of politicians
deciding things that would affect them
and their families for generations
without having a say that's why we need
a people's vote yet others may say the
referendum was so devices divisive for
the last thing we need is another vote
there's no doubt grexit split families
and communities in the structural navin
district as well as the wider community
country but if we quit near you with a
bad deal that people don't want that
will be even more decisive I do respect
the original folk nobody has been asked
what leave option we prefer if any
option at all we should be given the
choice now so the government can pass a
people's mandate the department does
respect
after a people's vote in which the
public get to compare two realities the
country may be able to heal itself
whatever the result that would be
closure to this whole sorry story Thank
You councillor tachi
now we did have a referral and we had a
seconder to reject this motion and
therefore I'm going to call the vote on
that proposal also cousin was so so what
you have is the motion for this matter
which was seconded the motion happened
later on was about putting that question
to the vote which so we're back to the
original motion thank you right we're
not voting on councillor Morse's vocally
and seconded by Councillor check thank
you for that clarity mr. Grafton so all
those in favor of council Moss's
proposal
all those against councillor mosses
proposal
right any abstentions
twenty-two members present we have
thirteen against the motion and seven
for the motion the motion therefore
fails thank you for that if we can move
on then to 17 this is from note this is
for information only okay and then 18
there is no no items virgin business and
therefore I conclude the meeting